- When people leave
comments on YouTube,
"You suck", "You're not funny",
"You're not interesting,"
feel bad for them because if
they have enough time to leave
a negative
comment on your channel,
they've lost.
You focus on the positive,
put out content and here's the
number one key,
document don't create.
Don't over think it.
You can produce
unlimited content every day,
every day, every day.
Obviously you have
school and other things
but don't be crippled.
Don't be romantic
just do, do, do,
do, do, don't listen,
do, do, do,
do, do, don't listen.
("Legendary" by Welshly Arms)
What if I told you this was
the last Monday
morning of your life?
- We're in London, right now.
So Gary and I left
New York at 6:25 P.M.
That's when our flight
left but this flight sucks.
- [Gary] Off to London.
Gonna make some magic happen.
Across the pond.
24 hours of hustle.
UK style.
- When you leave at
6:25 or 6:30 whatever,
you're not tired so
you can't go to bed.
And when you arrive in London
you start at the
beginning of the day.
("When We Got On" by Job
ft. iiAmEzee &amp; K-OH)
- Facebook video
is so important to me.
- Mhmmm.
- I just want us to
be the best at that.
I believe it's the
modern-day commercial.
Influencer marketing, I just
want to go deep and execute for
clients that, you know?
What I'm trying to go against,
what I'm paying much more
attention to is do they think
about retention and growth not
how much do they make.
You know what are
they worried about?
That's what I'm
more fascinated by.
Are they on the offense,
do they know how to up-sell.
Do they have
the CEO relationship?
Like one of the biggest things
that I'm pushing everybody for
more is farming not hunting.
- [Raisa] Yeah, totally.
- You know?
- [Raisa] Which is what
you were saying
five years ago to be fair.
- Yeah.
Last year I was very passive
and wanted to watch the natural
behavior of leadership.
Plus, we had a whole
restructuring of our creative
capabilities really.
You know we have six GCDs now.
We had none at
this point last year.
("When We Got On" by Job
ft. iiAmEzee &amp; K-OH)
Going in to see
a potential client.
No cameras allowed.
See ya, Raf.
So that was fun.
First meeting in the bag.
Just really kind
of introspective.
Was walking out of there,
it was incredible to be sitting
in a room with one of the
biggest companies in the world.
And just having the level of
conversation we're having
around content, distribution.
I mean when we started Vayner
with AJ and I started Vayner in
2009, people didn't
even know what Facebook was.
You know people didn't
even believe in digital.
And here we are
eight short years later
and people
really having
detailed,
knowledgeable conversations.
Just fun to see the world evolve
and I'm sure the pioneers of
television had that sense
that blood was in the water.
Right? That, okay it's coming.
It's coming and so people are
not being romantic
about radio any more.
They're starting to understand
the television is real.
Television's in every
home and so I'm excited,
it was a good meeting.
- [Gary on Phone]
Snapchat, Pinterest,
Instagram right now and so when
you do something you have to
know your craft.
Clouds, dirt.
- [Gary] Facebook commercials
and influencer marketing will
continue to be the
big push in the org,
so, two things.
One, I just want
that in your mind.
I like the idea of that being in
your mind for you walking down
the street randomly
and saying to yourself,
"You know what I'm gonna
ping Andy K from Gary team."
You may not even
know that, great.
"I'm gonna ping Andy, I just
want to get the analytics on
"Gary's long form videos on
Facebook," or things like
"You know what, let me hit up
Giswaldi or Dunk or," it's just
gonna be the thing and so the
more your brain knows that,
the better.
("When We Got On" by Job
ft. iiAmEzee &amp; K-OH)
We couldn't time that better.
- Uh, no.
But you'll be here,
I think you're coming late--
- [Theo] Yeah!
(Gary laughs)
- How are you?
- So, so fucking good!
- [Gary] What's your name?
- Oh my God!
My name's Theo.
- Theo, nice to meet you.
- I'm from Manchester but I just
traveled all the way down here
walked an hour from the trains
to get here just to see you,
speak to you, man.
But I said last year, this year
I'm gonna come and see GaryVee.
A friend of mine
said, "You know what?
"I might know something
for you." (Gary laughs)
"He might be here."
So I was like,
"Fuck! I need to be there."
- I'm running so
late for a meeting.
Do you want to get a picture?
- Yeah, can I get a picture but
I'd really love to run
something over with you.
- Say it as we're doing it.
- Okay.
- And then maybe we'll set it
up an actual call because
I'm really, really late.
- [Raf] Yeah,
we already talked.
- Let's do it.
(camera snaps)
- That's quality.
- Give me some contents
and then email me right now,
Gary@VaynerMedia--
- Yeah, done, done.
- I'll forward it to Tyler
and I'll get us 15 minutes.
Give me the framework.
- It's a sports app.
- Such a pleasure, man.
- Respect, man.
- Thank you for the love.
- [Theo] Respect. Big love.
- [Gary] Yeah,
I can jump in here.
I think from my
perspective, first of all,
thanks for your time.
I'm always paying attention to
market behaviors and things that
are going on in culture and
how I interplay with them from a
personal brand side
and my agency's side and
you guys have really crushed it.
It's super impressive and truth
is I'm not really looking for
anything at all other than
starting to meet people
and build relationships.
My favorite move is
how do I bring value?
I am, yeah.
I'd love to meet you and get a
better sense of like how you're
thinking about things and hear
your story and that story and
your overall arching
kind of like world as well.
I love reverse
engineering, right?
The more I know, like
I'm real, real long term.
So like, three years
from now, nine years from now.
So, I think it's a marathon,
so I'd love to meet too and
I don't even like phone calls.
Like I really just love
face-to-face so I'm looking
forward to that.
He comes through
New York once in a while.
Not that often.
To me, it's a good time of year,
I would recommend getting to
Chicago if you can because
they're still
planning their money.
You wait 'til March or
April when he's in New York,
they may not even have it if
they wanted to do something.
That's my recommendation there.
And then, Mike work with Tyler
and get us together in New York.
I'm away the next two
weeks filming my show in L.A.
but I'll be back after that.
(hip hop music)
So I posted something
about saying you're an
entrepreneur is different
than being an entrepreneur.
Somebody left in the comments
that they usually agree with me
but then once in a while
I just blow up and blow it.
And their point was
that teachers teach,
they don't
degrade their audience.
It's so interesting to me
that a statement like that is
interpreted as a negative.
I actually think I'm helping.
I'm trying to help the millions
of kids that have been sold on
the propaganda that
entrepreneurship is for
everybody and they're not
deploying self-awareness
to who they actually are.
And so to me, just 'cause
you're getting critical feedback
doesn't mean
you're hurting somebody.
Think we've gotten so soft in a
lot of arenas that even debating
something that may not feel
warm and fuzzy is met with the
thought that it's a negative.
I can tell you right now that my
parents taught me a ton of shit
that wasn't
delivered with honey.
And so, I think we need to
debate what teaching is really
about and more importantly that
there are many delivery styles
and ways to deliver a message
and not all of us react the same
way to every one of them.
And so, some people respond
extremely well to one way and
some respond to others and
I think the earmark of trying to
provide value is trying to
reach and communicate to many
different people
many different ways.
("That's Right" by
Job ft. Kno'Bodie)
What up, Instagram?
Love you guys.
Hope you're doing well.
That's it.
- Eric!
- Good to see you.
- [Gary] Hey. How are you?
- Real pleasure.
Big fan, Robert Gaholie.
- [Gary] Such a
pleasure, Robert.
Hey guys!
How are ya?
Good to see ya.
How are you?
Hey.
- [Eric] Who's
the number one seed?
- [Gary] Yo!
- [Group] Hey!
- Hey.
- How's it going?
You good?
- [Gary] Good seeing you, man.
All good stuff.
'Sup man?
Good to see you.
'Sup, bro?
- Sorry, that was
a terrible high five.
- How you doing?
That's alright.
Got to have some bad
ones to have some good ones.
Hey!
- Hi!
- How are you?
- How are you? I'm good.
- Good to see you.
Good to see you.
See you later.
Such a pleasure.
Hey!
- Hi. I'm Helen.
I don't think we've met.
- No, how are you?
- I'm good.
How are you?
- Good to see you.
- How are you?
- Really well.
- Good.
Did you sleep on the flight?
- No. I've really not
figured out my way.
I've got to figure it out but
I think I got a
concept this time.
- Hey, I'm Marcus.
- Marcus, how are you?
Real pleasure.
Perfect, are we going inside?
- [Eric] We're gonna
go to a conference room.
- Okay.
- I just want to say hi.
- [Gary] Hi.
- I'm Jessica Gioglio.
You gave me an
endorsement for my book.
- [Gary] Is that right?
- I wrote it
with Ekaterina Walter.
- [Gary] Yes!
- Yes, I know--
- How are you?
- I haven't seen
you in a long time.
- Yeah. How have you been?
- It's good to see you.
- Yeah.
- You doing well?
- Yeah. Really good.
I'm hosting a
startup event here tonight.
- Awesome.
How's it going?
- Good, we're gonna
kick off at seven so--
- Awesome, good luck.
- I'll let you go.
I know you're
busy running around.
- Awesome, good
to see you. Yeah.
Good to see you.
- Good to see you.
- Hi.
- Hello. Jen.
- Jen, Gary, nice to meet you.
- [Jessica] Bye.
- [Jen] I love you, Gary.
- [Gary] Thank you so much.
(crowd chatter)
How are you?
- Good. I'm really good.
- [Gary] Good.
- [Man] This is super,
super honor and privilege.
- [Gary] Thanks, man.
- [Man] I'm really,--
- [Gary] That's really kind.
- [Man] I'm a big fan.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- [Man] Do what you got to do.
("That's Right"
by Job ft. Kno'Bodie)
- [Gary] We'll continue
the conversation, my firend.
- I hope so.
- Can you send this
to me in digital form?
- [Man] I will.
- Gary@VaynerMedia.
- [Man] There's some
names on the back,--
- Okay.
- [Man 2] I just
wanted to give you some--
- It's great.
- [Man] granularity.
- I'm a weird dude.
I'll make way more decisions
on this than I will on that.
What I tend to do is I want
to make sure that you're not
vulnerable to
what matters to me.
There's a guy who's
about to get blown out and
just didn't hear me.
- [Man 2] Right. No, I hear you.
- Cool. I got to do this.
- [Man] Thank you so much.
- Good to see you, brother.
- [Man] Really a pleasure.
- Stay well.
- [Man] Take care.
("Bandit" by Job)
- Hey.
Yes, sir, of course.
- Big fan.
- Thank you, man.
- Thank you for
everything that you're doing.
- Thank you, brother.
- (inaudible) to start and so...
- Good for you, man.
Let's do it.
- Can I do a small video?
- Just a quick picture 'cause
I'm so late with her
I don't want a--
- Sure, sure.
Thanks a lot, man.
- Keep it up, man.
Thank you for
the love, take care.
Love you, pal.
See you tomorrow?
- Yeah. Alright.
- Alright, London.
Going to head out.
Going to the hotel now.
Gonna go work out.
I got to work out now.
Whatever it is, 10 o'clock and
then I got a work out at 6 A.M.
Fucking Jordan.
See ya.
See ya tomorrow.
What's up guys?
What time is it?
I don't know.
It's alright.
11 or something.
- [Jordan] 10:10.
- 10:10 and Jordan's
making me do 300 push-ups
(Jordan laughs)
in the next 40 minutes.
This is what my life's come to.
Trips from New York to London,
no sleep and then because
I needed to get a quick one hour
nap in I have to work out at
10:10 and tomorrow
again at 6 A.M.?
- [Jordan] Yep.
- What are we doing tomorrow?
- [Jordan] Legs.
- Yeah.
("Bandit" by Job)
- I'm like, wait, he's in
the corner there and yeah.